all right it is mailbag time here on pf
tpm monday edition let's get right to it
at washington fan uk did heineke do
enough to warrant being the starting
quarterback of the washington
football team shireen williams your
immediate reaction to the unexpectedly
strong performance from the guy that
most people can't spell his last name
right including me
i think he certainly did enough mike to
warrant a contract for next season and a
chance to compete for that job i don't
know if one game in the playoffs in a
loss gives you a chance to be named the
starting quarterback but i certainly
think you should be able to compete for
that job i expect him to have kyle allen
back just because of ron rivera's love
affair with kyle allen we don't know
about alex smith's future for sure and
maybe they get somebody else who knows
what they do at that position going
forward mike i do think they need to
have somebody they can groom
to be their future quarterback and maybe
that is ty taylor heinecke maybe we'll
see enough to to know that but at this
point i think he's done enough to at
least compete for the job
alex smith has a salary next year in
excess of 18 million and no further
guarantees on his contract so that
becomes a factor in whether or not they
want to keep him he has to decide
whether he wants to play many would say
you've proven you can come all the way
back you make us nervous every time
you're on the football field after what
happened to you a couple years ago
please call it a career and move on he
was the first overall pick in the 2005
draft as to heineke
my concern would be
he put it all out there he emptied the
tank he went all out in one game
viewing that as his audition for the
future you can't play like that and be
healthy week in and week out if you are
a team's quarterback you can't dive for
the pylon you can't take the physical
risks he took with the season on the
line you have to dial it back or you
aren't going to be available to play and
there was a point where it looked like
he was going to end up in the locker
room and not available he got back and
he didn't miss any time that's my
concern you can't be that reckless week
in and week out or you aren't going to
be healthy enough to play a full season
and secondly
it's one thing to see what he does in
one game where they weren't ready for
him it's another thing to see what he
does week in and week out when you're
generating film that gets study and
broken down you pick up his tendencies
you pick up his tells you know what he
likes to do you know what he doesn't
like to do and you're game planning
against him how good is he going to be i
was
i was surprised that bruce aaron's the
buccaneers coach said after the game
they wanted alex smith they were
concerned about heineken's mobility and
he failed in getting all of his players
to buy into the idea
that it wasn't an easy victory if smith
doesn't play shireen so there's
potential there but it still needs to be
developed and harnessed he has a place
in the league i don't know that he's
done enough to earn a starting job
because i don't think we would see that
type of play week in and week out in a
way that allows him to keep playing week
in and week out
absolutely mike you know ron rivera said
i think it was earlier today it might
have been yesterday that
he should have had a quarterback
competition before the start of this
season and he didn't do that and they
obviously named dwayne haskins as a
starting quarterback on day one and it
didn't work out for him haskins is not
even on the roster now so this is a team
that really looks like it's ready to
compete mike except at that quarterback
position there is a huge question there
and we all know
if you don't have a good starting
quarterback you don't have a chance in
this league
you're absolutely right and that is the
thing that they will be looking for
throughout the offseason no stone
unturned i know some think that cam
newton and ron rivera will be reunited
in washington i will believe that when i
see it i see another question at lens
trm do you think a carson wentz frank
reich reunion in indianapolis would be a
good idea for both parties shereen what
do you think
well you've proposed this mike and i
thought it was a great idea i mean he
had his most success under frank reich
but now you have to wait and see who the
head coach of the eagles is and i have a
feeling that they're going to get almost
like the houston situation they're going
to get a head coach that can that thinks
he can anyway revive the career of
carson wentz whether he can actually do
that or not i don't know but i think
that's the direction they go i think
that this a lot of doug peterson not
being there has to do with carson wentz
and i think they still think ownership
i'm talking about front office i'm
talking about still thinks carson wentz
can be a winning quarterback in this
league
and they have to figure out who the
coach is and what the coach wants as we
said earlier they got two quarterbacks
there now for the coach to choose from
and there had been this expectation
wentz was going to be on the way out
they haven't decided yet that wence is
on the way out if he is on the way out
then maybe you look into trading him to
the colts if the colts are interested
there's a a dance to this as well if you
seem
too intent on trading a guy you're not
going to get maximum value look at what
the eagles did with sam bradford in 2016
they carried him on the roster he was
the week one starter supposedly carson
wentz was the rookie who was going to be
backing him up supposedly teddy
bridgewater tears in acl they get a one
and a four for bradford see you sam
carson pick up the football you're in
that's what they will do if they get
what they're looking for for carson
wentz they're not going to do anything
out of desperation and they're not going
to set it up for themselves in a way
that forces their hand and from indy's
perspective carson wentz versus phillip
rivers if you think that carson wentz's
performance this year was an aberration
with the product of 14 different line
combinations then it makes sense to get
those two together again but this is all
part of the cloak and dagger keep your
cards close to the vest say something
other than what you believe reality of
the off-season because if you're too
candid about your thoughts about your
preferences about your plans
you end up either giving up too much to
get a guy or not getting enough in
return for a guy if a trade happens
jags walker broken record but what's the
latest on urban meyer in the jaguars
timeline and possible gm pairing someone
told me today that urban meyer is
waiting until after tonight's national
championship game ohio state clemson
doesn't want to do anything to take away
from ohio state he's still got the loyal
following there he's still viewed as
kind of like coach emeritus they still
love him there so he doesn't want to do
anything to screw that up so maybe
tomorrow these discussions or whatever
it is that's going on between the
jaguars and urban meyer will continue
look
this is his job if he wants the jaguars
have made zero effort in the last two
weeks to push back against this
perception if it's not true they need to
get a pr person on the forum on the
phone with everyone in the media who's
saying this is where it's going and
saying you're wrong that's how it works
hasn't happened so it's myers if he
wants it does he want it do they want to
pay him what he wants these are all
things to be worked out as to the gm
candidates
scott piolli was one of the names that
i've heard trent balckey who's the gm
there for now is a possibility
and another name that popped up this
weekend ray farmer the former browns gm
apparently there's a relationship
between the two from their mutual time
in ohio to keep an eye on shireen but uh
meyer if he takes the job not just
hiring coaching staff he's hiring the gm
which means he's in charge of that
football operation with
no
nfl head coaching experience
and i think that's another clue mike the
fact that they haven't hired a gm yet
that urban meyer will do that hiring if
he gets hired as the head coach and i
think that's a clue that they haven't
moved on the gm job like say houston has
with getting nick casario in there
letting him hire the head coach or
deshawn watson hiring the head coach
however that works out but the fact that
they haven't hired that gm yet and are
going to let urban meyer do that i think
that's another clue mike that this is
who they really want they've zeroed in
on him and it's his job if he wants it
now the question is does he want it i
believe he will be the next head coach
of the jacksonville jaguars just a
feeling there there are still some
people who think he will get to the
brink
and he will say
this isn't for me he's 56
and he's got a history of being highly
successful at the college level the nick
saban example is something that i would
study as closely as possible because
saban hated the first year was tormented
the second year couldn't wait to get out
and landed at alabama and look at what's
happened for him there
and the fact the lions aren't in on
meyer tells me that chris spielman who
knows urban meyer knows that he would be
too tormented by life in the nfl to ever
be functional at a high level on a
sustained basis as an nfl head coach
let's jam in one more here dr j144 are
people serious when they ask if mitchell
trubisky deserves more time in chicago
he's had four years he's due to become a
free agent they didn't pick up his fifth
year option he will hit the market
unless they sign him to a new contract
or use the franchise tag don't hold your
breath for that
do you think that trubisky and matt nagy
should should continue assuming naggy
and ryan pace are both back as gm and
head coach
i think that it's time for mitchell
trubisky to move on somewhere else and
see if he still has something in him to
become a good quarterback something like
ryan tannehill did and leaving miami to
go to tennessee mike i just think he
needs a fresh start somewhere else other
than chicago to see if he can make it
work
and that's the thing if you're the bears
if he leaves and he does really well
somewhere else boy you're gonna look
stupid and think about that they took
trubisky over patrick mahomes deshaun
watson they traded up a spot to get
trubisky over my homes on watson the
absolute worst case scenario for the
bears would be trubisky to go somewhere
else
and become a star
i don't put the chances of that
happening are very high but wouldn't
that be the ultimate slap in the face
for bears fans yes
oh absolutely it would mike and they
have to hope that that doesn't happen
but it could it definitely could
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports